foreign
[Music]
so we have been playing D4 pretty
religiously over the past couple of
games and we're going to continue that
today
we're going to start with D4 and we're
gonna play a queen's gamma decline uh
Queens of gamma domain
maybe our opponent will declining yes so
he declines it with the move C6 this is
the slav I don't think we faced the slav
or maybe we faced it once
the slav is one of it's part of the big
three
The Big Three is of course the Queen's
Gambit accepted the Queen's gamble
declined and the sloth these are the
three most reputable moves in this
position the three most reputable
responses to the Queen's Gambit so after
C6
of course we could play C takes D5
that's the exchange love but the
exchange slav is extremely colorless
unless you play a very interesting
variation that the vast majority of
people are unfamiliar with I am going to
introduce you to this variation now we
can play this through the move order C
takes D5 or we can play this through the
move order Knight C3 and that is the
boar variation let's take on D5 this is
sort of the pure way of reaching this
position now we play the move Knight C3
and whether or not we could play this
line hinges on black playing the main
move which is Knight F6 if blackley's
Knight C6 we have a second idea that is
also very dangerous that I will also
introduce to so either way we're gonna
get a good position here I can sense it
so this is the exchange love
if you follow the mainline Theory then
the exchange love results in a very
colorless position a lot of pre-arranged
draws are made of the exchange love
so for instance if you play the move
Knight F3 and black plays Knight C6 you
basically get a completely symmetrical
position that ends in a draw
like 75 of the time but recently in the
last 10 years or so people have started
playing The Exchange slot for a win and
the line that I'm about to show you has
been around I think for over 20 years
it's been around for decades it's
informally named after Carl Brandon Bohr
who is a feed a master I think he's from
Ohio he has championed this line he's
written about it he's played it and I
think he deserves uh the namesake of
this line and it is the move F2 F3 in
this position
now if you're seeing this for the first
time then
you should feel that this move is crazy
it violates essentially all principles
of development Violet's been feingold's
Golden Rule what the heck are we doing
with the move F3 but that's exactly why
I think this move contains so much venom
people don't realize how dangerous
Black's position can get and how fast it
can get dangerous I had a couple of
students who have played this move very
successfully
black has a clear way of equalizing
black is actually several ways of
equalizing but the vast majority of
people I would say below 2200 and in my
experience even players rated 2000 often
get completely lost in the complications
here
so what is the idea of the move F3 well
the idea should be completely obvious to
you the idea is to occupy the center
with e2e4
but that's only the tip of the iceberg
now the majority of people here with
black play the move Knight C6 and Knight
C6
is not necessarily a bad move but it
really allows us to execute and carry
out the main
gist of the idea of F3
is this played at the highest level well
not really and that is because most
people at a high level actually know how
to neutralize the move F3 and I will
show you how to neutralize F3 after the
game assuming that black doesn't play
the move the critical move in this
position
so it's not Bishop F5 here and I will
preface this by saying that I'm not a
specialist in the boor I I know like the
basics of it but it's entirely possible
that our opponent will make a move here
that I don't know so if you're watching
this let's say on YouTube you know don't
get too angry if I don't know the Mover
if I actually go wrong here it's
possible
Knight C6
okay so we ignore this move and we
continue with our plan we play the move
E4 E2 E4
and here we start to understand the main
idea of the system it may seem that D
takes E4 wins a pawn you might look at
this and say okay D takes C4 F take C4
black has two attackers on the D4 Fawn
white is only one Defender so Queen
takes D4 essentially wins a center pawn
and offers a queen trade what's good
about that oh well the point is that
after d takes E4 you play the move D5
this Intermezzo is missed by a lot of
players and it leads to a very very
dangerous position for black
so we play D5 we forced the Knight off
of C6 then and only then do we recapture
on e4 getting ourselves a major Pawn
mass in the center but all of that is
moot because black has played the move
E5 so already I don't know this move I
don't know E5
which I think
it means that it's not the correct move
but we're gonna have to think on our
feet here
okay so let's reason logically well it
seems to me that White's choices here
are really only limited to one move
it doesn't make much sense for us to
take on D5 if we play e takes D5 at the
very least black can take the pawn on D4
establishing a knight in the center so I
think the only reasonable move here
is to start with D take C5 I think that
yeah Bishop B5 is also possible but
Bishop B5 seems like an unnecessary way
to overextend ourselves like Bishop B5 e
takes D4 and then play Queen takes D4
seems quite awkward
just no need for that when I think we
just clarify the tension with d e
okay and this is a critical moment let's
spend some quality time making sure that
we at least
do our best to find the best move to you
so there's a couple of candidate moves
here that jump out immediately the most
obvious move is e takes D5 that wins
upon in the center
now the drawback of e takes D5 is that
our development isn't great that is the
main flaw of the bore system is that you
play the move F3 so after e takes D5
what I would what I'm concerned about is
black playing the move Bishop C5
developing the bishop to a really nice
score preventing us from castling and
just in general preventing us from
developing freely
so we should put e takes D5 aside as a
possibility and we should consider the
other candidate moves now noticing this
configuration of knights should lead you
to a very typical kind of idea in such
positions and this is a universal idea
across all openings that is to play F4
Chase one night away and when that
Knight moves away to drive the wedge
into Black's position E4 E5 chasing the
other Knight away and creating this Pawn
chain in the center
that to me looks a lot more appealing
than taking on D5
so I actually think F4 is the correct
move now you might wonder well why don't
we do the same thing while developing
our Bishop right shouldn't we develop
while doing the same thing but it's not
the same thing because that's your
Bishop F4 if the Knight drops back to G6
the bishop on F4 is going to be hanging
doing stuff with the pawn is generally
going to be safer let's go with F4 I'm
pretty confident that this is the best
move
probably means it's wrong but
at least it makes logical sense right
and now Ben Feingold can breathe easily
because we no longer have a pawn and F3
we'll have four Bishop G4 is not
dangerous that's just one moveitis right
Bishop G4 simply creates a one move
threat against the queen we have a
million ways to Parry that thread we can
play Queen B3 or queen A4 check so
Bishop G4 is not scary
okay
so let's pause here for a second just to
reconsider
okay we can play also e takes D5 the
fact that he has gone Knight C6 has
increased the appeal of taking on D5
because now this move comes with Tempo
so what happens after e takes D5 well
probably black is going to play Knight
before
but there I see another interesting type
of option
let's let's reflect on that position
just for a second I actually have to
think about it
because there's there's a lot of
complication hiding beneath the surface
so the what I see in that position as a
way to trade Queens by force
but even after a queen trade our King is
potentially a Sitting Duck anyone
oh
so as one of you indicated
the main deterrent to playing the move
E5
is the counter-attacking move d4
so after E5 D4 what happens there well
we probably are going to take the Knight
on F6
black is gonna take the Knight on C3
we will trade Queens Queen takes the
eight check let's say black plays Knight
68 and there
we play the move B take C3
black probably plays G takes F6
hopefully you're following this line
and by the way if you're watching this
on YouTube you can pause at this point
setup set it up on a board and make
these moves as I say them if you want to
follow in real time
so once again E5 D4 takes takes Queen
takes D at Knight takes d8 B takes C3 G
takes F6 how do we evaluate that
resulting end game where well both sides
have a deficiency in terms of their Pawn
structure but Black's King side pawns
are I would say worse than our Queen
side pawns the other good thing about
White's position is that we have a small
initiative we can quickly get our Bishop
to B5 with check and it seems easier for
us to Castle than for black to Castle
so I actually think that E5 is the
wisest continuation and after the game
I'll spell out some of my thoughts about
e takes D5 maybe the engine wants to be
greedy here entirely possible but I
think we should be principled and stick
to our initial idea with E5
okay you're welcome to follow with an
engine and laugh at me
but that violates the entire
Zen of the speedrun
if it's news to you that I'm much worse
than the computer than
you know
then you've been living under a bit of a
rock
yeah I think he takes D5 and Bishop C4
might have been a lot better
somehow I just don't want to be
greetings somehow I want to be
principled in the center
yeah we'll analyze after the game
so we considered the move d4
of course black can also move the Knight
where can he move it
well here she can move it to E4
um but in that case I thought that we
also get a better end game after Knight
E4
we probably want to refrain from taking
on D5 because we've got nothing
developed and black has this nasty
possibility of Queen H4 check that just
seems no good
but after 94 we can play Knight takes C4
D takes E4 and again we trade on d8 and
in the resulting position black has a
serious Pawn weakness on e4 which I
think we can attack by bringing for
example our Knight to C3 or to G3 I
think White's better in the end game
um
so what else can black do here well
black and play Knight G4
but after Knight G4 I think we can
already take the pawn with our queen
queen takes D5
so I actually don't and maybe this is -2
but I don't see off the top of my head
what it is that's so scary about this
position for why black has a lead in
development so maybe there is some crazy
idea that involves leaving the Knight on
F6 and playing a move like Bishop C5
accelerating the development maybe
that's the way but Knight G4 is on the
board okay
so
[Music]
um
well I think that we I actually am
beginning to see why we might be in
trouble here
um what I underestimated is that
actually Queen takes D5
black has this weird looking move Queen
B6
and all of a sudden Our Queen is left
stranded in the center and black is
threatening a devastating check on F2
so I just feel like black gets the
pieces out so quickly in that position
so I think we need to amend our strategy
a little bit and we need to try to
develop our pieces at all costs we need
to try to accelerate our development
before we start worrying about the D5
Pawn how can we supercharge our
development in this position well what
that essentially is asking is can we
develop with Tempo can we develop a
piece while simultaneously attacking one
of our opponent's pieces
well we can we can play Bishop E2
the crazy thing is that Bishop E2
doesn't actually carry a threat because
even if we take on G4 black can respond
with Queen H4 check for King The King
and the bishop
but that leads to a queen trade and that
in the event of that happening we play
G3 black plays Queen takes G4 and all
things held equal a queen trade should
be in White's favor white should benefit
in the event of a queen trade because we
are behind in development
on the other hand giving up our light
squared Bishop is potentially
problematic given how many weak light
squares we have in our position
so let's start by waiting for Black's
response the move I am most worried
about this is a very Advanced move I
don't expect him to play it that is the
move Bishop f8 to C5 because
he basically has to sense that Bishop
takes G4 meets with Queen H4 check and
realize that he can just continue
developing as if nothing is the matter
Bishop C5 is very very dangerous and
we'll figure out what okay great
all right
um
well let's think
maybe we'll just get crushed here
okay I have an idea
I have an idea
so just to spell out why Bishop takes G4
is bad it's so unappetizing if you can
follow along Bishop takes G4 Queen H4
check
G3 Queen takes G4
and the problem is that if we trade
Queens in that position yes the Queens
are off the board but our King is still
devastatingly weak and black can try to
swing this Knight into D4 there's just
way too many threats there and I don't
think we're we get a chance to complete
our development
so
I actually think that the best move for
white here
might be Queen takes D5
I think Queen takes D5 is the trickiest
move you can play in this position
so what does this move do well obviously
we're taking a pawn which is good
we are attacking the bishop and what I'm
relying on is that after Queen takes D5
Knight takes D5 we're also threatening a
fork on C7 so you might notice here that
black has the possibility of Knight F2
if black plays Knight F2 in this
position that's just bad because we can
take the bishop and then we can trap the
Knight on H1
if black plays Queen takes D5 first and
then Knight F2 we both essentially take
each other's note Rooks and then we both
try to get our Knights out of the corner
Bishop F2 check I was not expecting that
move
Bishop have to check
okay well I will bite let me go King F1
and we are pretty close to getting mated
here but I think the king is safe for
the time being
I think white is safe here I think
Bishop F2 might have been a mistake
unless there's some ridiculous follow-up
here like Knight E3 check I don't know
but 93 check we can already take on E3
and trade Queens
white is probably still worse but it's
defensible
yeah I don't know what the follow-up is
here let's see
and and the other problem of putting
minor pieces in such close proximity to
the king is that obviously there's now
contact between the king and the bishop
which means that Bishop takes G4 has
become a serious threat the bishop on F2
is a type 2 undefended piece it's only
defended by one other piece and that
piece is also Under Fire
okay
Bishop F2 check
I think is a mistake unless there is
some sort of
crazy follow-up here that I don't see
well Queen H4 is possible yeah Queen H4
is possible but then we can develop our
Knight with Tempo with Knight F3
type 1 undefended piece is a piece that
is undefended by any other pieces or
Pawns
so technically The Rook on A1 is the
type 1 undefended piece now that's
totally irrelevant because the rule
cannot be attacked
okay Queen B6
might be best yeah Queen V6 might be
best
yeah Queen B6 probably is best
oh that's a strong move
man you guys are good
Queen B6 is super strong because it
protects the bishop and it builds a
battery which threatens Bishop takes G1
and queen F2
now I think after Queen B6 we will have
to find a way to defend the F2 square
with another piece
but let's cross that bridge when we get
there our opponent's already getting
really low on time which is good
I think we will be able to survive this
would be six on the board wow okay
well
um
I think we have to go Knight H3 I don't
see another move
we developed the Knight but most
importantly we defend the F2 Square
taking the sting out of any bishop move
that black could come up with here
so
I guess the opening experiment has
misfired dreadfully yeah so F4 E5 is bad
intuition by me this was just bad
intuition I I assumed that this would be
strong but I completely underestimated
how much we're weakening our King
and how much the lack of our development
impacts the evaluation to be honest
Knight G4 I just missed Knight G4
like the only two moves I considered
here and I'll talk about this more after
the game where D4 and 94 and both of
these moves allow a queen trade Knight
G4 kind of keeps the Queens on the board
and gives black attacking chances
but okay the game is not over
we continue to defend we continue to
milk Black's clock down
93 check well we have no choice we have
to take
we have to take
Bishop takes E3
now we have to continue being very
precise so
to survive these types of positions it's
important not to get overwhelmed
it's important to understand what the
priorities are because you will not be
able to attend to every need in your
position right
pardon my French shit's bad right stuff
your position is going to be unpleasant
regardless you need to figure out what
the most important things are there's
two things in particular that you need
to pay attention to the first is what
the immediate threats are are there
immediate threats here does black have
something that is going to win the game
if they play it well there is right if
you look carefully you'll notice that
Queen takes B2 is a really really bad
move to allow because it's Forks the
rook and the Knight
so that's number one number two is to
figure out whether we have any ways that
we can orchestrate counter play right
whether we can get active whether we can
create counter threats that might serve
to deflect our opponent's attention from
the essentially the the the side where
he's attacking
and if you ask yourself that question I
think you immediately see an interesting
idea which is to play the move Knight G5
and create a threat against the F7 font
what does that move do well it threatens
F7 I guess what I'm asking is why is
that a dangerous threat it's a dangerous
threat because F7 isn't that easy to
protect
and you could say well Camp black just
Castle here the flag castles then the H7
Pawn becomes weak and we can drop our
Queen down to D3 attacking H7
threatening made in one the other thing
that Queen D3 does is it vacates the D5
Square for the Knight and Knight D5 is
going to be a fork against the black
queen and the bishop
that essentially is what my idea is in
this position with Knight G5
but that's not the end of the line if
you can follow against again bit of a
long line Castle's King side Queen D3
G6 Knight D5 black has Queen takes B2
counter attacking The Rook on A1
what is the move in that position ladies
and gentlemen after Queen takes B2 white
has a key move without which the whole
line fails and we might actually get
that
Rook B1 we play Rook A1 to B1 attacking
the Queen the bishop is still hanging I
think we can safely play Queen D3
now perhaps Queen E4 is more accurate
I don't see a difference off the top of
my head
I don't see a difference off the top of
my head let's go with my initial idea
with Queen D3
we'll have to compare after the game but
a very important move to see Queen D3
right
how do you see this move well what I
essentially the first thought that I had
right is that the queen has essentially
done its job right the queen of the
center is poorly placed so my
inclination is always to move the queen
away from the most vulnerable Square
let's go with Knight D5 I think our
opponent is relying on Queen takes B2
notice also that there is a potential
check on F6 this is not that dangerous
for black at the moment because there's
just King G7 but something just a mental
note to make to yourself
well if Rook d8 if Rook d8 here then at
a minimum we can take black screen black
takes Our Queen and then we can actually
take either of the two Rooks and we have
a big material advantage as a result
and I think we are officially out of the
woods
I think we are officially out of the
woods
yeah Knight D5 I think Queen takes B2 is
going to happen and then we're going to
play Rook B1
and after Rook B1 Queen takes a two
with what piece should we capture the
bishop on E3 Let's test your
visualization the queen or the Knight
the Knight exactly because the White
Queen is still going to be making
contact with the Rook we cannot admit in
the black queen I mean we cannot abandon
The Rook with our Queen
so we take back with the Knight even
though it's a retreating move we have to
keep our Queen
in defense of the Rook on B1
Kings Gambit asks what about Queen takes
B2 Rook B1 Bishop F5 well the simplest
there would have just been to take black
screen and then to take Black's Bishop
Bishop F5 is desperation
let's keep it simple here right you
might start calculating Knight takes B6
Bishop takes D3 Knight takes a a it gets
complicated there Bishop takes E2 and
Bishop takes F4 and black could end up
only being down in exchange there's a
much simpler move just take the damn
Bishop just take the damn Bishop you
don't have to calculate anything or of a
piece
now I briefly asked myself the question
can we move the queen away with check
the answer is obviously no but that
should be your first instinct in a
situation where both Queens are hanging
you should go down a clear list the
first question can I move my queen away
with check can I move my queen away with
a maid threat so if the H3 Square were
accessible if the H4 Square were
accessible Queen H4 would essentially
win the queen here
once you answer no to those questions
then you start looking for Desperados
moving the queen away with Tempo moving
the queen away capturing a piece here we
can just take an undefended Bishop Queen
takes B2
now the last step that we have to carry
out before we win the game is we need to
consolidate our position is still all
over the place our King is on a
vulnerable spot our Rooks are
disconnected we need to make sure that
all of our pieces are centralized
defended and we need to repel the last
stages of lacks initiative so the nicest
move here I think is King up to F2 yeah
very good because not only does this
protect the Rook it also connects the
Rooks it brings the king onto a square
where it's just sort of surrounded by
all of these defensive pieces
now some of you might look at this and
say but I don't want my Bishop to be
pinned but again
it's all about how many times the bishop
is defended it's defended twice it isn't
attacked a single time other than the
queen black has no effective way to put
pressure on that Bishop
and if we need to we can bring a rook to
E1 either Rook to E1 and protect this
bishop even further
so
the higher rated you get the more you
have to
sort of concretized as kind of an
awkward work but I don't know how to
describe this process essentially take
general principles that 500 rating
points ago you would just sort of accept
as a fact like I'm not going to play
King F2 because it walks into a pin
but when you're higher rated you have to
understand that not all pins are
dangerous and you have to become better
at Discerning which pins are dangerous
and which are not
okay
now I see a way for us to trade Queens
by force we could have done this on the
previous move I just missed it
let's do it here Queen C3 very good we
can see three-fourths is the queen trade
notice how this works the black queen is
undefended so Rook takes D5 we simply
take the queen
B6 is covered by the Knight D5 is
covered by the bishop black has to trade
we're up a piece in the end game that's
it as I mentioned I think in the
previous speedrun game this is just a GG
move you don't have to calculate
anything else once you've determined
that you're getting the Queens off the
board because you know that you're going
to convert up a piece and black just
resides
so a quick game 20 moves but a lot
happened in those 20 moves
A lot happened in those 20 moves
so
all right so the opening experiment was
an abject failure I apologize for that I
thought it would work better
now as far as I know
as far as I know
the move that most slav players and slav
books recommend is Queen B6 in this
position
and the point is that E4 is met with d
takes E4 F takes E4 and E5 counter
striking in the center
I think the most similar opening to this
is the fantasy Karo Khan in fact the
crazy thing is that we might almost have
a transposition to the fantasy I mean
it's not exactly the same because in the
fantasy there's a Pawn on C6 but it's a
very similar theme
if you consider the fantasy Karo
and what I'm talking about is the Karo
Khan opening
the fantasy variation is this very sharp
move F3
so black is a line where he goes Queen
B6
Knight C3 and E5 this is a reputable
variation it's not that good for black
because after de5 Bishop C5 there's the
move Knight A4 without this move this
line would work like a charm
but notice how similar this idea is this
idea of going E5 in order to weaken the
B6 G1 diagonal sorry I guess A7 G1
diagonal
so here it's the same concept Queen B6
E4 takes takes and E5
and the point is that if white takes on
E5 there's Knight G4
and White's just got a bunch of gaping
holes there's a made threat The Bishop's
coming to C5 blacket's a huge initiative
so the main line is Bishop B5 check
now I think Black Goes Knight C6
after D5 I think black is supposed to go
Bishop B4 here
which leads to incredibly sharp
complications but I'm almost positive
that Queen B6 is the
top engine move in this position
let me pull up chess base just to
confirm this for you
yeah so according to my database before
we jump the gun here F3 was first played
in the year 2000 by a guy named
kleinhines
boor played it in 2004 so he wasn't the
first to play it the highest rated
player to play it was like 2600.
yeah Queen B6 is good
Knight C6 of course is the most popular
move
I think
the line that most people tend to
default to is Knight C6 E4 and E6 I'll
get to that in a second I think black is
worse in this position
yeah the top engine move is Queen B6
e4d4fe5
yeah Bishop B5 check Knight C6 so what I
just showed you is indeed the top Engine
line
and if
you play D takes E5
and queen V6 is almost never played this
is a very uncommon move most people
don't know to play this
so after D5 Knight G4 the engine line
continues Queen E2
now black is supposed to play the weird
move Bishop E6
another
strange developing move the point of
this move is to take the sting out of
Knight D5 so that it can be met with
Bishop takes D5
now there's a queen trade Queen B5 check
black trades on his own terms we don't
take on B5 allowing white to develop the
bishop instead we Parry it with Knight
C6
and you get an end game Queen takes B6 a
takes B6
and if anything I think black is for
Choice here Knight F3 Bishop C5 you can
tell how nicely black has developed
their pieces
white is still currently up a pawn I
think it's equal objectively but white
needs to be careful
so
yeah Bishop C5 instead of Bishop E6
is possible but here there is Knight D5
here there is Knight D5 so Bishop B6 is
the only way to stop Knight D5
um so unfortunately I'm kind of busting
the bubble here in terms of
uh the board but hopefully not that many
people watch this video
so let's transition to the game
continuation
I'm pretty sure that E5 is actually
really really interesting
I'm pretty sure that E5 is really really
interesting so 1964 I'll show some lines
here a little bit later
um
I want to check the engine after E5 ooh
so
actually
I'm not that bad
this is really interesting
496 F4 is the second engine choice
but after Knight C6 E5 is a horrible
mistake
so I actually went down the right path
at first but here we're supposed to play
e takes D5
and after night before Oh this is what I
missed so here's what I missed here's
what I missed after 85 night before who
can tell me
what the most tempting developing move
is for white like what's the move that
your hand is just playing automatically
yeah it's Bishop B5 check black
responsive Bishop D7
and now the only move that I can search
Queen A4 is worse Bishop C4 is too slow
because I think black has
Bishop C4 black has Bishop F5
and the threat of Knight C2 is very
annoying so you're probably going to end
up playing Bishop B5 check here anyway
you might as well do it here after
Bishop D7 the only thing that I
considered was Queen E2 check
the idea being that Bishop E7 loses to
D6
the bishop is pinned it is lost because
after Bishop B5 you can actually play
Queen takes B5 but even stronger as
Knight takes B5 the pawn on D6 is
protected the bishop is lost white wins
the game
but black covers with the queen
and your first instinct might be all
great right this is what I missed you're
trading Queens everything is awesome but
the queen trade doesn't solve
White's problems there's the threat of
Knight C2 there's the threat of
recapturing the pawn you have this nasty
Pawn on F4 that's sticking out like a
sore thumb and preventing The Bishop's
development it should make sense to you
that black is doing
fantastic here black is better White's
gonna end up losing the pawn and White's
position just sucks but in this position
there is a key computer move without
which white is simply worse
and that is the move D6 I simply this
move escaped my mind D6 in this position
and uh there's a crazy line that the
engine gives
which is tradition B5 Knight B5
black has the move Queen A5
now you might look at the whale I don't
get it Knight C7 check and Knight takes
a eight but that gives black a huge
initiative
so instead you should give a check on E2
now the line continues King D7 and now
the incredibly cold-blooded Knight F3
the point is to be able to meet the pin
against the queen with a 95 check
and if black goes after The Rook if
Black Goes Knight C2 check and Knight
takes A1 then white orchestrates a
devastating attack on black skin
so basically here you go
so Knight F3 Knight C2 King F1 Knight
takes A1 actually King F2 is more
accurate
King F2 is more accurate to be able to
involve The Rook 31 you don't want to
obstruct The Rook Knight takes a195
check
and the attack is totally and utterly
devastating for example 95 check
ing C8 and now the simple Bishop D2 ends
the game because the Rook is coming to
C1 and there are 550 different uh
mates for example Queen takes A2 Rook C1
check
now there's a very pretty Maiden two
Knight D7 check and Queenie a mate if
you really want to rub it in you can
even Stack The Rook on C at first
um so this is very one-sided I mean you
can tell that White's just totally
killing it here
so for that reason in this position
black has to go Knight D3 check double
check
the King has to slide over and black
plays Queen takes B5
and all of it all of this line converges
onto this particular resource without
which everything would fail who can spot
White's move
yeah 95 took very good the queen is
undefended
which means that the Knight cannot
recapture
the King has to take D6
and now it is very important to avoid a
couple of false positives right false
Temptations the first is to avoid taking
on D3 too quickly if you take on D3 too
quickly you give black the e-file and
you give black the initiative if you
take on F7
you might say oh this is great I can
take on F7 then I can take an eight
that is also bad
um and let me just confirm
why
so that is bad because Black's King dips
to C7 and here you're missing the forest
for the trees right you can't just go
after random material here look at
White's King you're just getting
checkmated here you have no pieces
developed
finally Queen takes D3 should be avoided
because after the trade you just have an
equal end game or maybe black is even
slightly better
so instead you need to make a
ridiculously patient move you need to
realize that white has to bring pieces
into the game as quickly as possible in
particular The Rook on A1 has to enter
the game via D1 so you play a simple
developing move you play Bishop E3 but
this move should make perfect logical
sense to you you don't just want to take
the Knight on Black's terms you want to
capture this Knight with the Rook so
that whitesnite remains on an optimal
attacking Square the Knight on D3 is
going absolutely nowhere it can't move
because the queen is pinned and after
Rook D1 it will be pinned to the king so
even if white black moves the queen to a
defendant Square Rook D1 pins the Knight
again and this time you're capturing it
on your terms it's plus over minus
according to the engine it's plus one
but black is in a lot of danger here
so because of this very simple line
how can you miss it
the key move being D6 my mistake was to
play the movie five here I was too
principled right I didn't sufficiently
consider deviating from my strategy
now in my defense
in my defense
um
well after Knight eg4 which I was
expecting the correct move would have
been H3 and now indeed the best move is
to play E5 but here the situation is
completely different because the knights
are super misplaced
um so after Knight C6 E5 Knight G4 is
correct and the evaluation is indeed
pretty dire for white it's it's minus
it's minus three almost
um Bishop BQ is indeed the top move
so
ooh yeah we were we were completely lost
at some point I'll show you how black
should have played
very instructive very instructive indeed
let's rewind really quickly to this
position I just want to show you what
the main line is in this position now
the most popular move according to the
database is E6 but here white is solidly
better you go E5 you play F4 and you
basically get a really good french right
you go Knight F3 Bishop D3 White's quite
clearly better here even according to
the engine
push through D5
and after 95 F takes C4 this is a highly
dangerous position for black a lot of
games here go E6
and now white simply continues
developing with Knight F3
and if you just blindly trade and go e
takes D5
and there's this line Bishop E5 check
and E5
and black is in a lot of trouble here
black is in a lot of trouble in this
position because if he takes on B5 I'm
pretty sure you play e takes F6
creating a threat against G7 and a
threat against the bishop and just in
general this is very very risky for
black so these types of lines is what
entices people to play the boar and this
happens often at sort of the club player
level you can dig around here on your
own you can sort of pause the video open
up an engine and if you really want to
get to know these positions you can just
analyze on your own
but I don't want to talk about it too
much still awake but finishing very
shortly
um
in any case
after E5 the 595 F4 we made a critical
mistake we played E5 and immediately I
realized what I had done I just
completely forgot that this Square
existed so Bishop B2
Bishop C5 excellent move by our opponent
understanding that Bishop takes G4 is
not dangerous because of Queen H4 check
and queen takes G4 and once again
very important to understand that just
because the Queens are off the board
doesn't mean that in some sense your
king is automatically safe or weak
squares don't count you can get
checkmated here just as quickly as with
the Queens on the board
hopefully that makes sense so for
example let's say you play H3
okay not a big deal the bishop can drop
back let's say to F5 or maybe even to E6
and black is on the verge of crashing
through with a move like D4 or Knight D4
there's too many weak squares in White's
position white is not able to hold on
here
Knight B4 is very dangerous as well
maybe the engine will find a way to
survive but
for a human this is virtually impossible
so for that reason we decided to go the
full nine yards I didn't see another
move other than Queen 65.
um
so Queen B6 another or sorry Bishop F2
check this I think is a critical mistake
I think this move as tempting as it
looks is a big mistake that gives white
a newly Sun Life
right you want to save this move for a
rainy day you don't want to play it just
because it's a check putting the bishop
in close proximity to whites King
actually makes things worse that's what
a lot of people don't realize about
Bishops they are best as a long range
piece and you don't want to quote
unquote move in before you're absolutely
ready for it
so for example if white plays Knight H3
here which we probably would have done I
think the winning move is just Knight D4
you just continue putting pieces in the
center and continue creating threats and
white gets overwhelmed here White's
White's position is collapsing it's the
only way that I can describe it is that
White's position is collapsing here
Knight A4 is always met with Queen A5
Chuck
Knight A4 is never dangerous as long as
the king remains on E1 because of the A5
E1 diagonal
yeah Knight D4 is just destruction
and try to make a move here for white
you can't Castle
Knight C2 is threatened and I guess
white can try Bishop D1 but I think
black can simply Castle here
and white is totally paralyzed
she guess proposes 94 instead of Knight
H3
94 might be the best chance because
Bishop takes G1 would be a terrible
mistake due to Knight D6 check
yeah probably 94 is the best that white
can do
but my guess is that Bishop B4 check is
probably the winning move
and after Bishop D2 again I think the
simplest is to Castle kingside and by
the way moves like castles
has a lot of trouble for players like
finding moves like that is hard because
when you're attacking you often get into
this Frame of Mind where you think that
every single move needs to carry an
obvious threat
but it's just as important to make moves
that bring new troops into the game
yeah 94 I'm checking with the engine
Bishop before check Bishop D2 castles is
indeed winning
and same goes for King F1 in this
position the top engine move is just
another developing move Bishop F5
prepare to bring the Rook into the game
all right remember these types of moves
and don't assume that every move has to
be a sacrifice or a check when you're
attacking white whites King is going
absolutely nowhere you're not actually
in a big rush by the way Bishop F5 does
create the threat of Queen takes Bishop
takes you phone Queen F2 Main
so Bishop F2 check according to the
engine
is
yeah it's equal after that after King F1
Queen B6 not H3 white is actually
slightly better which I think might be
an exaggeration but no but but the
entire attack evaporates that's how much
of a mistake it is to play Bishop F2
check
so after Queen B6 the top Engine line is
indeed 94 Bishop before checking F1
Bishop F5
now white is supposed to play Bishop
takes G4
which was we have already established if
you have to give up your light squared
Bishop that is a terrible sign
because then you will have to
permanently deal with the weakness of
the light squares
now in order to stay alive the only move
is Queen D3
rook d8 and Bishop E3 and white has no
choice but literally
to give up oh but after Rook day three
look at the engine looks like what is
just down a piece for nothing
but the engine sees what really pretty
defensive resource here
this is just crazy I mean once these
moves are made you should see this
quickly once these moves are made you
should see this move quickly
yeah there's Knight F2 there's Knight F2
but here black has the simple Rook D4
you give up the bishop on your own terms
Rook takes F2 F4 check and Knight takes
E5 black is a pawn up and just look at
the state of White's position this is
minus 3.5
this is technically winning but not
totally over white is still somewhat
kicking
you know so this is how the engine
defends Queen D3 Rook d8 Bishop V3
that's why no human would be able to
survive this position for more than two
moves even at the top level
but these are the kinds of tricks you
have to find if you want to stay alive
in a position like this
so anyways Bishop F2 check spoils
everything because it gives us the
potential to play Knight H3 with Tempo
every Tempo is golden in positions like
these
every Tempo is golden position like
these and after 93 check we are already
winning with Knight G5 the queen D3 idea
indeed wins the game now what's
interesting if we fast forward a little
bit apologies for that ID3 check this
should be three Bishop B3 we take over
the initiative with Knight G5 the best
defense is counter attack
s to remember the checklist when you're
defending on the one hand you're trying
to make a list of the top priorities
what is the biggest threat
on the second hand you're trying to
figure out whether you have any
realistic chances to start a counter
attack with pieces that could be
activated
93 check was a subsequent mistake it's
already plus over minus the best move
according to the engine is just to drop
the bishop back right this is not
glamorous but it keeps the attack going
now after take Stakes Knight G5 castles
what's hilarious is that Queen D3 is
indeed an inaccuracy Queen E4 is much
better and the reason why is after Queen
D3 G6 Knight D5 now our opponent's move
loses immediately Queen takes B2 is a
lot more resilient after Rook V1 let's
see if anybody can find the most
resilient move for black it's still
losing it's still plus three and a half
but Queen E4 would have been plus six
and there's a specific reason for it
this isn't just some computers Babble
you know
not Queen D2 not Queen D2 because here
Knight takes C3 keeps everything
protected but you're close Queen D4
now you might say well it's the same
thing or spin 960 but ah there's Queen
takes up for check white keeps the extra
piece with Knight F3 but black is able
to win another pawn and all of a sudden
black has two pawns for the piece that
Queen D4 is winning white should be able
to convert this pretty effortlessly
but Queen E4 eliminates the need for all
of that
because if you use the process of
comparison you just literally make the
same moves in takes B2 Rook B1 well
Queen D4 now you have Knight takes E3
and the F4 Pawn is not hanging
all right so most of the time that you
have two candidate moves that look very
similar the best thing you could do is
just to compare them by examining the
same variation going down the line and
figuring out how one move you know
impacts the position versus the other
move
so I actually gave
um a student an example of that exact
thing earlier today I if you guys are
interested I can show you a good example
of using
the process of comparison to deter to
distinguish between two tempting
candidate moves that both look like they
do the same thing
it's white to play here
and the goal is for white to win the
game it's a complicated position the
goal for white is to win the game
white wins with only one accurate move
everything else is either a draw or loss
now
how do we even begin to approach such a
position well we need to get our
bearings right we need to get our
bearings by figuring out how white is
even going to try to surmount the loss
of a piece we're down a piece well if
you look at this for a couple of moments
you should see an idea right the idea is
to force a rook trade and if black has
only one Rook on the eighth rank then we
will be able to overwhelm that Rook with
our pawns and with our other Rook so the
two ideas that immediately come to mind
are Rook a B1 and Rook a C1
the ideas are exactly the same we want
to go Rook CA and we want to go Rook B8
so for example let's start with the move
Rook a B1
if black makes an empty move such as
Knight F6 or something then we want to
go Rook B8
obviously if black takes twice then we
promote and this is checkmate
and if black
does not act right if black if black
does nothing then well it's easy we play
Rook takes A8 we play T8 Queen One Way
Or Another We're Gonna overwhelm Black's
forces with only a rook
but now we start looking for defensive
resources
and after Rook ab1 we need to ask
ourselves well can black use the knight
in order to somehow disrupt the
coordination of Black's Rooks of White's
Rooks
so who can answer that question what can
black try to distract White's attention
from the threat of Rook B8
well there's the move Knight E3 and
there's the move 93 it attacks The Rook
and I said well there's not not a
problem right if you go Rook B8 now
black plays Knight takes D1 and wins we
don't have enough pieces
so clearly we have to preserve the
stroke and we probably have to keep it
on the D file
so
well the simplest seems to be Rook D2
it simply seems to be Rook D2 because if
we go Rook D3
sorry well if we go Rook D4 we blend of
The Rook if we go Rook D3 then black
continues to harass us with E4
but this is where process of comparison
comes in
let's like in ingrain this position in
your mind
we are comparing this position
and this position and there is one key
difference that if you detect allows you
to distinguish between these two moves
who can tell me what this difference is
why do you need to keep it on the
default well we need to keep the D7 Bond
protected
exactly after Rook D2 black does not
have the key resource Knight C4
attacking The Rook why is that resource
dangerous well if we go Rook B1 93 Rook
D2 and Knight C4 again we have to move
our rook and after we move it the Knight
jumps back to D6 intercepting the rook
in the pawn and black wins because Rook
B8 is no longer effective black is now
able to capture twice on B8 and if white
does nothing then black takes on D7 on
the next move
so the move is Rook a C1 after Knight E3
we go Rook D2
and black is not in time Knight F5 Rook
C8 Knight D6 here doesn't work by a
Tempo takes takes Rook B2 and Rook B8 is
Unstoppable
so nothing in
more of a technical calculation exercise
by the way Knight F6 here there's a
pretty line you go Rook C8
black takes twice
you play Rook B1 aiming for B8 black has
one more defense Knight D7 and now we go
Rook B7 just the domination of a rook
and two pawns against the entire Army
the Knight is hanging if the Knight
moves you go rugby it if the Knight is
not moved and you take the Knight you
come back to B7 and then you go to B the
king is completely confined by this
deadly Pawn on G6
why is Rook DB1 not winning
so Rook DB1 is not winning
it's a good question
I think it's not winning because of
Knight F6
I think it's not winning because of
Knight F6 Rook B8 does not come with the
same effect
as Rook B8 if the Rooks on D1
right The Rook on A1 is a lot worse than
the Rook on D1 because here black can
play Rook debate and Rook takes B8
if the Rook was on D1 here then
promoting would be made here you have no
equivalent right again process of
comparison
so for that reason Rook dp1 is not as
effective as Rook ab1
if black takes the A7 Pawn to go Rook B8
this is the main point right you want to
go Rook B8 to distract Flex Rook the A7
Pawn has nothing to do with it
right it's it's only good and so far as
it forces black to give away one of his
Rooks
the G6 Pawn is worth its way in Gold
yeah but not to spend too long in this
the point is that you use comparison you
look at both lines simultaneously you
try to figure out like do you control a
certain Square in one of the lines do
you prevent an option that is one of the
hardest
tools to properly apply but it's
incredibly important so just wanted to
sort of introduce you
it even if it's hard the starting
position is winning yeah the whole point
is that Rook ac1 wins the game
but Rook ab1 does not it actually only
draws
so back to the game I think after Bishop
F5 Queen takes E3 we can stop here
because the rest was obvious King F2 and
had I noticed Queen C3 we would have
played it here I just didn't notice this
move to be honest
I I fell for you know I was too focused
on defending the Rook but once we saw
Queen C3
we played it because as far as the queen
trade and black resigned because
obviously we're simply up a full piece
here
so only 20 moves but nonetheless a very
rich game both opening wise and I think
in terms of the Early Middle game so the
lesson here is again well I Mis
evaluated E5 I was too focused on trying
to evaluate D4 this is a common thing
that happens when you spend a lot of
time trying to evaluate one particular
move you often forget to go back to the
initial position and make sure that
you've examined the other candidate
moves properly I'm sure you guys can
relate to this right you spend five ten
minutes pouring over a line it turns out
the line works out for you to get
excited so you play the move then all of
a sudden you're like wait I didn't check
the other variations properly so as I
was mentioning during the game
I spent some time trying to evaluate the
send game BC GF I thought the white is
slightly better here because our
development is a little bit more
efficient we go Bishop B3 and then we
Castle queenside
I also evaluated 94 and I thought okay
we trade queens and I think white is
reasonably better in this end game
but
I completely forgot that 94 and D4 not
the only moves
well I can keep the initiative with
Knight G4
very instructive I think very
instructive moment and the ability to be
flexible right the ability to go for a
lie in our move with one idea but based
on your opponent's reaction to stop on a
dime and change your approach this is a
good example of that my idea in playing
F4 is obviously to follow up with E5 but
after Knight C6 I should have taken this
move and updated my perception of the
board and realized that e takes D5 is
now the correct way to go of course I
would have had to see the move D6 which
I missed
such as life this is what you have to
notice in complicated positions any
questions
thank you everybody
and I will see y'all later
[Music]